yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
your data is your business protect it
at expressvpn.com yang
i know you you've been uh advising the
biden campaign i
advised biden on deep fakes uh two years
ago
do we have the technology right now that
could go through and be like fake fake
fake fake fake fake and then there's
one real one in there and be like real
so right
could you have a tool that gives you
like a spectrum of probability
yeah and and that is how those detection
tools work right now the ones that are
already out there they're like oh this
is 90
probably synthetic but in four years
time when it is
time for the next election some experts
who i speak to think that as much as 90
of video content online could be
synthetic so oh
gosh i think there's a short window in
which something can still be done
i mean a democracy can only work liberal
democracy can only work if you have
some kind of objective reality and some
commitment to truth and the pursuit of
truth
if the pursuit of truth no longer
matters then the only thing that matters
is power
and now it's my pleasure to welcome to
yang speaks
author expert on deep fakes and ai and
misinformation
commentator uh trained at cambridge
university among other places the
amazing nina scheck nino welcome
great to be here andrew thanks for
having me
oh i think you're hammering away at
themes that that
are so important and that people are not
paying enough attention to
so how did you come to become an expert
on ai and deep fakes because most of us
know that they exist but we haven't
spent years studying them the way that
you have
well andrew my background really is in
geopolitics
and information warfare so i come at it
from a kind of national security angle
and i've spent the last decade really
working at the heart of some of the huge
political events
in europe and across the pond in the
united states
looking at kind of the russian invasion
of ukraine what's happened around the
brexit vote what happened in 2016 with
the u.s election
and increasingly been starting to see
how the information ecosystem
is corroding to the extent that the age
of information
which has been around for the last few
decades really has become the age of
disinformation it's dominated by bad
information
and this was something that we saw state
actors
taking advantage of in the past few
years but increasingly also something
that
you know influencers and lone
politicians
are uh using to their own benefit not
to mention the president of the united
states so when the kind of recent
emerges of the ai community in the form
of deep fake
started to come out in the last two and
a half years it was like oh my goodness
this is the most potent disinformation
tool
that is about to hit we've been terrible
at handling the corrosion of our
information ecosystem for the past 10
years
we are not ready for the age of
synthetic media so
that's really how i came to it from a
kind of geopolitical angle
but it's far far broader than that and
it's pervasive in
every aspect of life synthetic media
uh is that simply anything that i
alter so if i were to take a photo of
myself and then
you know make myself look better
like does that does that count as
synthetic media or or is it
strictly if you're doing something where
it's um
deeply false and misinforming no so
i mean as long as like the visual media
has been around humans have been trying
to tamper with it right
not to mention for example in the 20th
century stalin was doing that he had
a whole cottage industry of craftsmen
who are trying to manipulate photographs
to
kind of smooth out his pockmarked face
however
that at that time without modern
technology it was pretty difficult to do
but increasingly over the past few
decades you know as things like
photoshop and instagram
filters have become more accessible it's
become easier to tamper
media but synthetic media is the next
step
in the evolution of tampering with media
because what synthetic media is
is media so it could be an image
a video or a piece of audio that is
wholly or partially
generated by ai and what that means is
it's going to make it
easier than ever before to create high
fidelity
fake video audio and images at a scale
that we have
not seen until this until this point
[Music]
so the deep fake that people might be
acquainted with
and you include a couple examples in
your book deep fakes the coming in
pocalypse by nina shikh so
if you are freaked out by this stuff and
want to see what the background is and
what the future look like this is the
book for you
i learned a lot from it so the most
prominent examples that people might
have
encountered there there was a video of
barack obama
uh saying things that he never said that
was produced with buzzfeed
um there were i believe some celebrity
fake porn
not not that i've seen them but i know
that they're out there that like people
are
putting celebrity faces on uh other
people
um so those are some of the examples of
synthetic media that people
might have seen uh are there other
ways that we encounter synthetic media
like maybe without even knowing it
well andrew we are just at the start of
the synthetic media revolution
and as in so many things porn has been
pioneering it's only been
a practical reality for about two and a
half years this is when kind of the
ai research became a practical reality
and it started on reddit where
an anonymous user calling himself deep
fakes made these synthetic
video creations which were fake porn of
non-consensual fake porn of
female celebrities and since then that's
when i first encountered it at the end
of 2017.
we have started to see deep fakes
leeching out into politics
not only to politics but into business
life for example there was a huge
instance last year of a ceo who was
conned out of 250 000
because some crook used a deep fake to
emulate his boss
calling him and telling him to wire
money
but the most prominent use cases so deep
fake
could could be one of those kind of
mission possible
sort of voice simulator things too so
people are thinking of it as an image
but it could be an audio
yeah it can be a video or an audio and i
think the
number one thing to impress on to the
listeners
is that basically ai is getting
sophisticated enough to hijack your
biometrics so
i take my ai machine learning system and
i feed it training data which in this
instance if i want to emulate you andrew
i can take a clip of your voice
unfortunately there's a lot of video of
me you could probably get a pretty good
one
you would be an easy person to deep fake
because of your public profile i could
just go on the internet
find a bunch of videos find a bunch of
audio clips
feed that into my machine learning
system so the ai can
be trained to emulate your voice your
likeness
and then i can make fake audio clips of
you or i can make fake video clips of
you saying or doing anything
and because this technology really is
still so nascent we're only at the very
beginning
it's getting better so much quicker then
it's getting better so quickly that soon
it's not even people who are only in the
public eye but
anybody so if there's a five second clip
of you there's a video of you on
facebook
um anywhere on the internet you also are
fair game so it's not only celebrities
or politicians who are in the firing
line it's really everybody and you
already see that
because in the first use case
non-consensual pornography
normal women are already being targeted
so when you
see what's happening in porn it doesn't
take much to realize
how that's going to percolate into
politics
it's going to shape geopolitics and it's
also going to be something that every
private citizen
and every business needs to mitigate
against
so you reference the fact that stalin
had been doctoring his photos for a long
time
and in your book you catalogued
russian leadership in this space it
seems like russia has been
investing significant resources in
misinformation for
quite some time uh can you talk about
those investments that that they've made
uh and what those resources look like
yeah so i my premise is that our entire
information
ecosystem has become increasingly
untrustworthy and dangerous
and i start my story really with russia
because russia is the master of
disinformation and before
our entire information ecosystem became
broken
russia was channeling the spirit of bad
information
even during the cold war um they were
masters of disinformation and used that
really to punch above their geopolitical
weight
so one really famous and audacious
disinformation campaign that the soviets
ran in the 1980s
was the lie that the cia
invented um hiv aids in order to kill
african americans
now in the 1980s that was them
and you you know that that is now still
a cultural reference point it's
mentioned in the wire
it's mentioned in you know some rap
songs it is something that
disproportionately affects if you talk
to public health
officials african-american community to
this day
in the 1980s that myth took
10 years to go viral however
now the russian strategy has not changed
but what has changed
is the information ecosystem and the
tools which they can
use to infiltrate our kind of
national debate and they did that to
great effect in 2016.
so in 2013 the russians were very very
quick to set up
they call it so so just to rewind for a
second so they've been doing this since
the
1980s so they've got 40 years of
experience with this
and you reference the internet research
agency the ira
in your book uh and so it brought to
mind for me that there are
buildings full of hundreds of russian
engineers and disinformers
uh one of the the reasons why i was so
struck by this track record is that i
ran for president
most people know and um what what you're
doing
often is you're creating or your
supporters are creating various social
media accounts
and they're a relatively recent vintage
so they could be
you know two weeks old two months old i
mean you know like there there was no
like nebraska for yang before
you know like quite recently so then
like if a social media account pops up
you're like oh that makes sense
um but in some of these cases russia has
been planting
these seeds for years and years so you
could show up on the scene and see some
social media account that's been in
place for like eight or ten years which
makes it seem very very
uh real you know it seems like well
there's no way someone could have faked
this
uh where where and even for a normal
user
when someone um says something to you
that's like you know
nasty or or whatever and then you go to
their account and you're like oh this is
like a brand new account like this
thing's not even real
this is totally a bot um but
in russia's case they've actually been
creating accounts for so long
that you could stumble upon the account
it could be eight ten years old with
thousands of followers
yeah absolutely i mean if you look at
the architecture of our information
ecosystem i mean social media
smartphones haven't been around for that
long
russia has played the long game so when
it came to the influence operations
in the us they started in 2013
three years before the u.s election
actually happened
and what they did was create like you
mentioned
these social media accounts where they
posed as authentic americans
and played identity politics so they
built groups
across the political spectrum so it
wasn't just them agitating kind of in
favor of trump supporters they were
building groups across the political
spectrum
and they had a two-pronged strategy the
first was to build up
tribal identity so it could be you know
on the right for kind of
gun owners or texas secessionists and on
the left they disproportionately
targeted the african-american community
and what they did after they built up
these tribal identities
as we got closer to to the election was
inject these groups full of
political grievances often they would be
legitimate political grievances
and in the case of the african-american
community as we got closer to the
election it was in order to make sure
that they didn't go and vote so saying
things like
hillary clinton is not a president for
black americans neither is donald trump
we need to sit this one out
we don't know to so i think it'd be
foolish to say
that the election was swung by the
russians but what is an
uncontrovertible truth um something that
all of the u.s intelligence agencies
have now established
is that they intervened in the public
debate
so it's very alarming to see
that this is something that the
president of the united states refuses
to engage with
and something that's become such a
politicized issue in the united states
because
what that means is we can't defend
against this
enemy who is trying to break american
democracy from within
so this image of a building
and hundreds of russian engineers uh and
designers
and uh content creators that's real
like like there is that building there
are these hundreds of people
they've been doing it for years and even
decades
to the extent that we have any
measurements around the scale of the
resources do we know how many people
work at the internet research
agency in russia and do they have any
legitimate opportunity
like they have any legitimate activities
or is like the entire internet research
agency
just um just uh pitting americans and
i assume europeans and other people in
other parts of the world
like uh creating fake accounts and
putting us against each other
well i in my book i quote um
a soviet kgb defector he gave an
interview in the 19
in 1984 in which he said that the
majority of the resources
of the kgb the forbearer to the russian
intelligence
services was spent on spreading
disinformation
right so it wasn't on spying as such it
was actually to spread
disinformation so that your enemy or
your target is inundated with
so much information that they can't come
to
the right conclusion in their
own national interests or in their own
interest so the ira
has a tremendous amount of resources the
russian state
invests a lot of resources into
disinformation operations it's something
that has
always allowed it to punch
geopolitically above its weight
um but the i would the other point i
would say is that they're always looking
for ways to evolve
because having a bunch of agents in st
petersburg
is what they did in 2013. but in 2020
what the ira has been doing
is actually getting agents on the ground
in ghana posing by the way as though
they were working for a human rights
agency
to spread this kind of content on
american social media platforms so
it's become quite easy to infiltrate the
public debate
even with limited amount of resources in
the sense that
some of this stuff was paid for but a
lot of it just goes viral organically
and you don't even need that many agents
to start making an impact
why would they cite that in this
in ghana at a human rights or sounds
like a fake human rights organization
um is that because our counter measures
uh are somehow less effective if they're
coming at it from
another location well i mean it's in
order i mean they've been
tremendously you know creative in a way
when it comes to finding ways to disrupt
american democracy
so the mo in 2016 to 2013 to 2016
was the troll factory in st petersburg
right by the way that was only one
way in which they intervened in the
american election
another thing that they did was the
classic hacking and dumping the dnc
server we know that
as well as attacking election
infrastructure the social media
influence operations that i'm talking
about they're inventing new ways to do
it because
we they know that the intelligence
service the intelligence agencies know
what the
ira did last time around so this time
when you have the front in ghana and the
interesting thing about
the front in ghana was that a lot of the
people who were hired
at this human rights agency they were
basically given a lot of the memes and
the content that went
organically viral in 2016 they didn't
know that they were working for the ira
they thought they were legitimately
posting social media content for this
human rights organization in ghana
because a lot of it again was focused at
the african-american community
so they're just very creative at finding
ways to use
the architecture of our information
ecosystem to meet their geopolitical
aims
um yes and they have a ton of experience
at it it was really
fascinating in your book seeing just how
deeply rooted
in um their
approach to international relationships
that that they just feel like they
benefit if other governments or other
societies cannot
come together uh and that felt very dark
but also it made a lot of sense i think
you referred to putin as something of
like a real life
james bond super villain yeah and i
think this is really
um what's at stake here with this
election
not only for the us but for the rest of
the world because
whilst um foreign disinformation foreign
interference
has been happening and russia is really
what i say the master at this kind of
operations
yeah and there was a princeton study
that said that
uh well so you cited two studies one was
that um we're up to 70 countries
that are participating in some form of
disinformation up from
maybe a couple dozen a number of years
ago but a 2019 study said that
russia alone is responsible for 72
percent of all disinformation
that they could find so even though
there are a lot of players this really
does seem like
um like a russian near monopoly
absolutely but that is starting to
change and
uh when we look at foreign
disinformation operations russia
undoubtedly is the most sophisticated
but now more of the rogue and
authoritarian nation-states in the world
are starting to get in the game
notably china china has been very good
at disinformation
traditionally at its own population
where it has a long-term strategy
just like russia does but due to the
hong kong protests last year and with
covid where it has so much to lose
geopolitically
china is starting to become more like
russia and its information operations
they've been aggressively trying to
penetrate western
social media platforms to do the same
kind of
chaos strategy that russia has been
doing since kind of
2013 to great effect
but aside from all of the foreign state
actors who are in the game
we can't talk about how damaged our
information ecosystem is without
recognizing
our homegrown disinformation in the west
and arguably
the biggest and most potent and most
dangerous player
in when it comes to western
disinformation is none other than
the leader of the free world so given
that this is what america is facing and
i know that a lot of the attention on
the election will be
domestic but it has meaning for the rest
of the western world as well
because all of the authoritarian leaders
will be looking at trump and being like
wow
if that's the game he's playing then why
should we not do the same
okay guys i want to talk about something
weird i want to talk about butts i want
to talk about butt stuff
we've got a a new sponsor for yang
speaks
and it's called tushy so here's the deal
most people suffer when they go poop
it seems like and toshi sent me a bunch
of research and i've done my own
research on this since they sent it
it's pretty interesting and real most of
us wipe instead of wash
and then there's things called bidets
that are really popular in europe
but they're not popular in the united
states yet um because they're so
expensive they cost thousands of bucks
to install
they're a pain but tushy is changing
that so hello
tushi has made a modern bidet attachment
to democratize the blessings bestowed by
the days that's their quote which i
think is hilarious and offer clean
buttholes to everyone
i can't believe i'm reading this this is
awesome all right but seriously
this product's great um i'm a wipes guy
not a um
a toilet paper guy but post discovering
tushy i'm now a tushy guy or let's call
it a bidet guy so
it saves paper it actually saves water
it's better for the environment
um it's pretty awesome no need to wipe
no need to buy toilet paper um so save
money save time and it feels great
so every hellotushy
bidet attachment comes with a 60-day
risk-free guarantee and a 12-month
warranty so if it breaks you get a new
one
or if you don't like it in two months
you can get rid of it
no harm no foul so join millions of
people are doing this
millions this is like the best kept
secret millions of people
are switching to tushy so here is the
deal go to hellotushy.com
yang and get 10 off 10 off is an awesome
deal special offer just for yang speak
listeners go to hellotushy.com
yang that's t-u-s-h-y hello tushy dot
com slash hang for 10
off you use water to clean the rest of
your body but we use paper
to clean our butts time to fix that so
let's talk about butt stuff on yank
speaks check out
hello tushy yang
it's awesome i'm a huge fan check it out
the picture you pain is very very
concerning and it seems like a lot of
the disinformation
um capitalizes on social media
and one of the things that we've been
hammering uh
on the podcast is that negative ideas
and sentiments spread more powerfully
and quickly
on facebook and social media platforms
um
than positive ones and so you know i
think that that benefits
people who are trying to sow mistrust
and these negative ideas
uh let's say magically i would just turn
off all social media
not not to say that's plausible or
desirable
but if one were to turn off facebook and
twitter and a bunch of these other
things
like is the prevalence of social media
uh the primary reason why
disinformation seems to be more
effective now
than it was in past periods
yeah i i think that first the first
point i'd say is that you know bad
information disinformation
has existed since time immemorial it is
fundamentally at its heart
not the technology that created it it's
it's a human
problem however what's happened in the
last 30 years
is that the architecture of an
information ecosystem has
changed so rapidly that we as a society
simply have not been able to keep up so
if you look at the huge kind of
transformations and breakthroughs in
human communication so
the invention of the printing press
which arguably changed
the history of um humanity you know the
reformation wouldn't have happened
without the printing press
to the invention of photography there
were 400 years between that so
society could kind of catch up learn to
navigate the new environment but over
the past
30 years we've had the internet social
media
smartphones and now we're starting to go
into the age of synthetic media where ai
can basically fake
any video or any audio clip we have
not been able in the age of information
to build
any safeguards into our information
ecosystem and the other thing
you mentioned the social media platforms
is that we have
these new arbiters of power
who are not accountable to the people
you know they're not elected so i think
there's a very
very important debate to be had and i
welcome you know
your interventions in this field because
i think this is going to be
one of the most important political
questions to get right
very important debate to be had about
who controls the information ecosystem
and who benefits from it and why do we
not have more safeguards because we
certainly need to and
so that's where i'd like to turn our
attention so let's take as a given which
i agree
and i i agreed before i read your book
and now
you know it's it's all the more
compelling that number one
um that there are foreign actors that
want to
foment unrest and mistrust in american
politics and american life american
society and i think most people
listening to this or watching this would
agree yes that's happening
two that the tools that they use to do
so
are getting more and more powerful and
compelling
and three now the way we get information
through social media
um the fragmentation of media and the
polarization
also makes it so that the
techniques that they use will become
more powerful and harder to stop
so let's take those three things as as
true which i totally agree they're all
true
uh we can all see it and feel it uh so
now
let's imagine that um i'm the president
or you're talking to the president i
know you you've been advising the biden
campaign um is that correct i
advised biden on deep fakes uh two years
ago
when they three years ago pretty yeah
pretty recent vintage
um what are the safeguards and
countermeasures that we could install
because a lot of people listening to
this right now nina are like oh my gosh
like i give up like i think i'm watching
andrew yang talk to nina sheik but maybe
i'm not
like you know this whole thing could
just be like a giant fabrication which
it could be theoretically
how do we know so so you do make some
suggestions but would love to talk to
you about what possible solutions look
like what could we do if let's say
hypothetically we have control of the
government of the united states of
america
2021 we look up and say all right we
have to
address this problem
yeah i mean the first step i think i
mean
as the old adage goes knowledge is power
so the first step
is just understanding what's going on
how
the entire information ecosystem has
been corrupted
and how this is playing out in all its
dimensions from kind of
the crazy geopolitical information
warfare to
homegrown domestic disinformation and
how that's corroding our political
system and i would say it's an
existential threat
to western democracies as well as how
you know
any company owner any business owner or
any private
individual can be impacted by this as
well so i think first thing
is putting it in a conceptual framework
and understanding how fake porn is
related to
deep fakes donald trump russian
interference
once you have that then you can start
looking at solutions and broadly the
solutions kind of fall into two
categories
the first is the technical solutions so
building the ai software to detect video
manipulations because as
synthetic media so yeah so let's start
with that nina
like let's say you're russia and you
make a hundred
synthetic uh media videos and audio
recordings
do we have the technology right now that
could go through and be like fake fake
fake
fake fake fake and then there's like one
real one in there and be like real
so right
is the answer because there are several
kind of deep fake detection tools but
given that they can be generated using
different kind of
machine learning systems there's no one
detection tool that can detect them all
and the other crazy thing about trying
to build
the detection tools is that because of
the way that this ai
works is that the better your detection
ability gets
the better the ability to generate right
so every time you think you build a
really cool piece of software ai
software to
detect all the fakes um you're giving
the person who's making the fakes
a foot up so it's always going to be a
cat and mouse game so
you're going to build the detection
tools the bad guys are going to find a
way to beat you so
there's never going to be one way to
detect them all um
right now again this has only been
around for about two and a half years
so there are some tools out there
there's no one universal tool is the
short answer
could you have a tool that gives you
like a spectrum of probability
where you could say this thing is
probably real
this thing might be fake uh within like
a certain measure of confidence i get
that you can't
categorically say real fake but you
could be like we think this one's
probably real
or we think this one's probably fake
yeah and and that is how those detection
tools work right now the ones that are
already out there they're like oh this
is 90
probably synthetic um but
uh i would say that because we're just
at the start of this
synthetic media revolution like we
haven't actually
come to the stage yet where it's
ubiquitous but in four years time
when it is time for the next election
some experts who i speak to
think that as much as 90 of video
content online could be synthetic
so oh gosh
there is an urgency which
isn't so it hasn't hit us yet but in
four years time
we're looking at something completely
different i actually think
this election is more likely to be
disrupted by something called the liar's
dividend
because if we live in a in a world
andrew where
anything can be faked right including
video which we tend to see
as authentic right which why video
evidence in court is
so powerful if everything can be faked
then everything can also be denied and
that is something called the liar's
dividend and you already
see that happening now and this is
something that's only going to get
more potent as time goes on there's
actually one candidate a republican
candidate
standing for congress who took the
george floyd video
that powerful video which unleashed a
movement not
only across the u.s but across the world
and she's written a 24-page document
saying that it's a deep fake so you're
going to see a lot more of that
[Applause]
[Music]
every day you see another story about
people's personal
data and privacy being hacked or invaded
and it's happening to all of us i don't
know if you saw the recent apple
commercials where they talk about folks
broadcasting personal details
and saying apple's better well one way
you can see two of them when you're
surfing the web
that your data remains secure is by
using
a vpn a virtual private network it's
like you're logging into some computer
far away that's nothing to do with you
and then anyone who's trying to figure
out what you're doing
actually can't tell and the vpn we
recommend here at yang speaks is
expressvpn
it encrypts your data hides it from the
world you can do whatever you want you
can access
content that's available in other parts
of the world which is a really nice
fun perk wired cnet the verge rate
expressvpn the number one vpn on the
market and that's why
we are so excited about it here at yang
speaks so to protect your online privacy
today with expressvpn
you can go to expressvpn.com yang
and get three months free on a
subscription that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang for three months free with a
one-year package visit
yang to expressvpn.com more
[Applause]
okay so there isn't an easy technical
fix
you can have some ai tools that catch
some degree
of uh synthetic media or some
proportion of it but not enough where
you can say problem solved so what else
what else lies in the technique okay so
so that the one the first part of
technical solutions is detection
the second part is provenance right so
you
actually try to prove what media
is authentic and this is going to become
increasingly important for like
activists journalists people who are
trying to record something
and hold someone either to account
as a kind of human rights abuse or to
show that what they have done
is authentic and you basically try and
embed that into almost the hardware
of your phone or your camera it's almost
like a watermark which is indelible
you can't tamper it so that always is
shown to be authentic
so those are the kind of two technical
solutions detection
and provenance but ultimately
this isn't a pro this isn't a technology
problem in the sense that the technology
here
until i mean we have fully sentient ai
which we don't
the technology is just an amplifier of
human intention
so the real solution comes with
policy legal
digital and digital literacy and
education
this is something that just the
technology isn't going to make go away
it's something that
society needs to grasp as a national
security and i would say
you know one of the most important
issues for the future of liberal
democracy so
if you were president i would say make
the
information ecosystem and the
architecture of the information
ecosystem shoring that up one of
the single top most priorities
of your presidency so let's say it is
our top priority which from this
conversation and your research
it really should be and i love the idea
of investing in provenance in a
particular way
because what it suggested to me was that
if you have a photographer
literally their camera on in the
hardware says
that nina took this photo and so you
could be almost like this official
documentary of truth and your camera
becomes this
uh capture of reality and everyone knows
like well this photo was taken by nina's
camera there's no faking it
this is this was actual truth
uh and so you could end up investing in
various
devices individuals organizations we
know your stuff is real
uh you know you took it on your camera
you'd be like yep that was me
on on my camera and i was there and then
we can have
greater confidence in it i think that's
the kind of investment that would make a
lot of sense
um and it sounds like that technology
is available to us it's just we're not
using it is that correct
it's being built so you have companies
like true pick adobe
qualcomm they're working on these type
of solutions and
again because this is such an emerging
field
it's something that they hope that will
be
built and then adopted as industry
standard within the next
you know two to five years so the
technology is being built
but then there's a bigger question of
does everybody
utilize it you know does does it become
kind of the industry standard so
in an ideal situation you would see that
there are kind of
detection tools that are inbuilt into
social media platforms because there's
going to be so much synthetic media that
it simply isn't going to be
possible for a human content moderator
to go through each of them and say well
this is fake this isn't fake and
moreover they won't be able to tell
because to the human eye it's going to
be impossible to distinguish
but on the other hand you're also
hopefully going to have all this
authenticity
software inbuilt into the platforms and
every
every point at which we engage with the
kind of information ecosystem
but there needs to be political will and
that's the real problem because right
now there are too many
political actors who have a vested
interest in the information ecosystem
being broken right unless there's
political will
and society-wide uh adoption
for this kind of architecture of our
information ecosystem it's just not
going to work
i agree with that i agree that you need
a
government in place that says look this
is a massive priority and we need to
invest in it accordingly are there
private actors
let's call it facebook let's say someone
from facebook's watching this and they
know
that these deep fakes are uh here and
growing
uh they know it could be disastrous for
ultimately their their business
uh you have these companies like
qualcomm that are investing
in the watermark technology could you
develop a standard independent of
government like could a bunch of leading
companies come together and say look
it's good for us good for our businesses
if we all just say these things are true
these things
we don't know if they're true or not uh
and not wait for government to get
attacked together
yeah and that is really what some
private actors are starting to do right
now so
um adobe is leading the content
authenticity initiative
with um getting images the new york
times the bbc's involved in another
similar kind of authenticity
initiative with microsoft so a lot of
the work towards this is actually
already coming from
the private sector um you've also had
kind of the big platforms engaged with
deep fake so kind of facebook and amazon
did this deep fake detection challenge
where they were trying to sponsor
uh various kind of ai solutions to find
the fakes
however um i think the platforms have to
be
more thoroughly engaged shall we say
because
they have become like i said the
arbiters of power in this new
information ecosystem so even though
sometimes they're
seen to be doing something like
launching a deep detection challenge
too often as the past 10 years have
shown us
um they've been slow to act on
disinformation and misinformation and
that has played out with devastating
consequences not only in the western
world
but across the world no one here
believes
that uh facebook's going to
necessarily get their arms around this
problem i mean it's obvious and
the upsetting thing um
is that it seems like facebook's
approach is to wait
until they have absolutely no choice
because of some um
degree of disaster or political or
public pressure
so i agree with you that you know
they're probably
right now uh thousands and thousands of
deep fakes on facebook and then they're
running this detection
challenge over on the side but you know
like in the right now that there's
uh not the right level of energy uh or
urgency
which we've seen again and again from
them uh
this is a massive uh
challenge and priority so those are the
technical approaches and then
that was like the first segment then you
had another segment yeah you were
thinking of was that the public and
political
yeah the public and political and i will
say i mean this would be my plea to you
this is why we need people like you
in public life people who understand how
the technology of the exponential age
is reshaping politics i mean my whole
shtick is talking about the information
ecosystem but
as you know there are far broader
applications than that
the whole age of automation which you've
often spoken so eloquently about but
we need people like you who understand
how technology is reshaping politics in
society and then can
communicate that to the public in a way
that they understand what's at stake
here
then only can i hope that there is kind
of the political and public will
galvanized in order to make this uh
the priority which i believe it needs to
be because
i think there's a short window in which
something can still be done
and otherwise the kind of vested powers
that
benefit from the information ecosystem
being the way that it is
it becomes increasingly difficult to do
anything about it and the crazy thing of
course is that they're
unaccountable to to the electorate this
will play out i think differently in
different parts of the world so
specifically in america and the west i'm
talking about the social media platforms
but of course in places like china or
russia where you have a more
authoritarian regime
it will be the government that benefits
from this so
i think we really need to have
a public debate about who
are the arbiters of power in this new
era of exponential technological change
what does it mean for privacy and
security and how
do we get kind of the public support to
do
something about it i agree with you and
thank you for
uh putting this on my doorstep because i
know because i agree
[Music]
okay this episode of yang speaks
is brought to you by stamps.com i'm a
huge fan of stamps.com
we use them on the campaign a lot
because i hate the post office i
actually got kicked out of a post office
recently
there's these ridiculous rules that you
need additional forms of identification
to open
a po box so i had my driver's license
and a passport and those were not
sufficient forms of identification which
to me is absurd
so uh i've got a bone to pick with the
usps
um although we like them for elections
and mail-in ballots and things like that
um a little upset so regardless
stamps.com lets you avoid that so you
don't get kicked out of post offices
like zach did so look stamps.com
they bring all of the mailing and
shipping services you need right your
computer and comfort of your home
your own home or office so whether
you're a small business sending invoices
like humanity forward or you're an
online seller shipping products or just
working from home and need to mail stuff
stamps.com is freaking awesome so
you can use your computer to print
official postage 24 7 for any letter any
package any class of mail
anywhere it's literally there's no
restrictions to stamps.com it's
fantastic so here's what you need to do
right now our listeners get a special
offer that gives you a four
week trial four weeks plus free postage
and
you get a digital scale um and there's
no long-term commitment you just do it
four weeks for free if you don't like it
get rid of it but you will like it
because it's great
if you're mailing stuff which we are and
i know a lot of you have to at certain
times so go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in yang so
stamps.com
go to the top of the microphone is and
type in y-a-n-g
get your four-week trial plus your free
postage plus your digital scale
that you can weigh stuff with i don't
know what you're gonna use that for but
it's free might as well take it anyway
four-week trial is pretty awesome
check it out stamps.com type in yang
one more note about stamps.com guys they
have a partnership with ups which is
pretty amazing so they offer ups
services what can brown do for you they
offer ups services with discounts up to
62
and no residential surcharges so
stamps.com is the place to go to ship
anything including the stuff that you
normally go to for ups you can do on
stamps.com check out stamps.com
so right now in the united states we
have deep skepticism
of the media i think the trust in media
that um
i saw most recently was 41 the major
media organizations
and it runs the gamut along party lines
so if you are a democrat in the united
states of america you trust
the national media at a higher level
let's call it 58 or 60 percent
and then independents are around 40
percent and then our
republicans are at something like 20
percent so so that's the
it's been migrating downward over time
so that's where we are right now so then
if
you go and say look we have to get our
arms around this
uh and establish what the heck is real
and what's not real like what's true and
and false
you have a significant proportion of the
american people already that are like
whatever you're doing
like i don't trust it it's nonsense like
you know you're trying to control me
control us
and there's a very very deep heritage in
the u.s
which i agree with freedom of the press
freedom of information
like censorship is terrible and it seems
like if you're trying to establish
what's
real or true then what you're really
trying to do is censor the heck out of
uh a bunch of people so that's like the
the current landscape
um and then you go to them and say no
look this is a massive problem
like you don't even know if i'm real
right now because i'm a
video screen so we would need to
line up in my view major media
organizations
major technology companies uh
non-profits
and the government and get everyone
together and say all right
like let us try and establish some
standards some rules of the road
to say that you have to use these
devices
and if you don't use these devices then
uh it will be marked as don't know if
this is real
uh you know and that can include our
cell phones so at least you know if i
take a cell phone video it's attributed
to me and like
you know so it's not like you
necessarily need to have a giant camera
from
um from cnn or wherever but like there
needs to be some
uh provenance to your point there needs
to be some kind of chain of ownership
of this and then someone like puts their
name on and says yeah
i was there and that happened um so
that's the challenge is trying to
bring that coalition together and then
try and get this trust
in whatever standards you establish
um to rise over time uh
in american life and it is it's
interesting how it does fall along
party lines in various ways
yeah i mean it's a massive challenge and
unfortunately i think the problem
is probably going to get worse before it
gets better
if you look at how polarized um and
divisive kind of the american political
debate is right now
and then inject the kind of the coming
age of synthetic media into that
i think it will the outlook looks
difficult to say the least however i'm
hopeful
that as things get worse um
you can take this networked approach as
it becomes
conceptualized as this national priority
that it can be approached this network
approach and this is the only way it's
going to work
if you look at other places where
society-wide mobilization to
disinformation has been really effective
take for example the small baltic state
of estonia
some 3 million people they've often been
in the eye of kind of russian
disinformation campaigns
and they've really turned it around by
basically adopting
what you just pointed out which is a
whole society-wide mobilization where
you have
kind of industry working with policy
makers working with citizens working
with ngos
but taking that networked approach is
really difficult
and i would say that if the current
presidency continues in the united
states then that challenge becomes
even more difficult because what's quite
clear
is that the president has a vested
interest in making sure that the
information ecosystem
is corroded he is one of the biggest
purveyors of disinformation
and if this continues for another four
years
i find it difficult to see the way
back for the united states so it's a big
challenge
no that's the argument that so many
people are making is that we can't
handle four more years of trump i happen
to agree with that
i think that four more years of
disintegration
will lead us to a point where it's very
difficult to come back
um though many people think of it for
different reasons than what you're
describing
you know but that there have been folks
who've said
that u.s democracy itself is on the line
yeah and i i don't think that's an
exaggeration at all because
if i mean a democracy can only work
liberal democracy can only work
if you have some kind of objective
reality and some commitment to truth and
the pursuit of truth
if the pursuit of truth no longer
matters then the only thing that matters
is
power and who has the power to control
narratives
so that then ends up becoming very
authoritarian the other places in the
world
where the only thing that matters is the
authoritarian nation-states and it's
no exaggeration to say that american
democracy
is on the line not only with
implications for the us
but for the rest of the western world
which is why you know with my kind of
background in geopolitics and european
politics we're
always looking towards the united states
because we know that whatever happens in
the us is really a harbinger for the
rest of the western world so
we're watching with tenterhooks as to
what happens in november
wow lots of lots of pressure on the us
to get this thing right
uh you know i i just thought of an i
just thought of a name
for this effort that needs to be built
something like the coalition of
authenticity
because everyone wants something to be
authentic like i don't think that anyone
could be
angry at that and that's really what
we're trying to to
shore up is the fact that if
i say something happened i recorded it
then it was
authentically um documented
uh because i was thinking frankly nina
about you know other things that just
sound
very heavy-handed and authoritarian
where if you had like that you know if
you use the word truth then everyone
would be like god
immediately become very very angry
because that's orwellian it's like we're
the ministry of truth we're here to tell
you what that's true
uh so you so you want to focus just on
whether the event actually happened
uh whether it authentically was
documented and you need a robust
political debate about because all of
the things that you already mentioned
the strong tradition
freedom of expression you know freedom
of speech all of these
tenets that are fundamental to our
democracy we don't of course want to
lose these
however we need to be realistic in terms
of
how quickly our information ecosystem
has changed and how we as a society need
to keep up with that and too
often we've kind of allowed the cool
technology to be built saying
there's going to be no downside but we
know that it's just an amplifier for
human intention so while there is all
this upside
what's becoming very clear is that
there's all this downside and we kind of
need to do something about it before it
runs away
um so i would say society needs to catch
up
with how quickly our information
ecosystem has changed and we can still
do it
while remaining true to kind of the
liberal values for freedom of expression
and um that is fundamental
yeah we just need to get our acts
together very quickly and dramatically
uh that this but this is such an
important
uh it's such an important conversation
and it's necessary for democracy to
function because if you don't have a set
of facts that
you can agree on or reality then how can
you
trust that people are able to vote in a
way that is supposed to be
according to the will of the people and
presumably in the public interest
the coalition of authenticity the
working title until we can think of
something
better that people will like better
we'll have to focus group that thing or
test it
but i'm with you and we need to build
this
hopefully we'll have an opportunity
starting in 2021 uh
but this is one reason why i am so uh
strongly for joe and kamala is i don't
believe that
truth will prosper in another
trump administration and that really if
anything the public trust will
degenerate to a point
where we're going to be unable to come
together and get much done
absolutely um and if you look at kind of
the polarization in the us
in the political discourse i mean it
predates trump but it is the at the
highest
level it's ever been under trump and
four more years of this kind of
environment
it's it's difficult to see how the
united states can come together after
that and as i already mentioned
the implications for the rest of the
world are dire
as well so we're counting on you
yeah counting on the u.s i mean those
are right now
like a lot of americans are like oh
[Music]
during the past six months i think one
of the things
that's been the most crucial as to how
we feel
about ourselves day to day is what we're
putting in our bodies
it's it's so easy when you're home all
day just to eat crap
frankly it's weird because you'd think
well i have more time maybe i'll make
something awesome for myself
and yet as a meal time rolls around you
just end up thinking like uh
you know um what do i have in the
kitchen and unfortunately a lot of the
stuff we have in the kitchen
is not that great for us
so one way to set it and forget it and
make it so that you have a constant
pipeline of healthy
food that's easy to prepare in your
kitchen
every freaking day is with freshly
freshly
is a way to actually just get these
meals sent to you
they're healthy they're balanced they'll
make you feel accomplished while
actually being easy and dummy proof in
terms of being able to prepare the meal
it's kind of incredible are over one and
a half million people that are using
freshly right now
because it's a game changer for what's
going into your body and how you feel
about yourself
and right now freshly is offering
listeners to yang speaks 40
off their first two orders at
freshly.com yang
that's freshly.com yang so you can start
eating better and feeling better about
yourself
so aside from estonia are there other
countries that uh you think have
implemented a set of best practices that
could be useful uh for us and others
estonia is really the best case study
because
they took kind of being in the eye of
soviet disinformation
ever since you know they stopped being a
soviet satellite state in the 90s
and really made it a national priority
here in europe some of the european
countries we still struggle
uh in the uk we still struggle as well
and that is because
again all of this is so new it's only
really started unfolding
uh to the extent where the complete
corrosion of our information ecosystem
has become
so prevalent is something that's really
only been manifesting
in the past 10 years so we're all
struggling
estonia is a beacon of hope and a lot of
the
interesting stuff is actually coming
from the private sector and there's
in the last chapter of my book there's
all these organizations working in civil
society
ngos who are also working towards this
but it's only just getting started so
that coalition still
needs to come together one example i do
cite favorably
is the bbc because it's publicly funded
and there are standards it adheres to it
issues corrections it gets fact checked
very very
uh diligently and even that when i've
cited that favorably in the u.s
people have not liked it being like oh
the government can't fund
media and i'm like well they're doing it
in other parts of the world
and it's like not everyone loves it all
the time but you know it's functioning
at a high level and
it manages to irritate people on like
both sides of the political
health spectrum uh so
is there a home for um
more publicly funded media as something
of a counterweight to the disinformation
that's out there because
and i know a lot of americans right now
are groaning because
americans don't like the idea of
publicly funded media i personally think
that npr and pbs
like do great stuff and as a parent
having my kids watch
some of the kids programming at pbs it's
like it's very high level
um but what do you think about
government
subsidized or funded media as one
counterweight
yeah absolutely i mean you're spot on
actually the bbc gets it from both sides
here so you know they must be doing it
right because
the left is always complaining of bbc
bias towards the right and vice versa
but there absolutely is a place for that
but even
if that doesn't become something that's
popular in
the american discourse and i can
understand why there are
loads of fact-checking organizations
that are already
doing brilliant work that deserve our
support
um because they really are our first
line of defense but again i
i see how problematic it is when you
think about how polarized the media
sphere is
in the united states that any kind of
fact-checking organization
which uri might think is you know being
an arbiter of the truth
this becomes a politicized issue so
there's a massive catch-22 and i think
part of that is because
the debate in america is already so
polarized and divisive
it's hard to see a way back
until i think there is this coalition
this joint effort
networked approach yeah we have to build
it
i'm just going to to tell a dumb story
from the trail
but the the exact the example of the
most boring
yet very very true to life programming i
think uh um
in american media is c-span where they
just stick a camera on various events
or the congressional hearings uh i don't
know what c-span's ratings are they're
quite low i'm sure but
uh it was a relic of the cable network
when they got all of their
uh their spectrum and allowances
uh then they said we're gonna donate
this channel
to to the public good
so so c-span has the most boring public
interest programming there is
um which is included uh many events i
did
because all they did was they'd just
stick a camera on the event
and i and so as someone who ran uh for
president you kind of forget the cameras
there so i'll tell
a story that you know maybe someone
finds entertaining um so i'm campaigning
in iowa or someplace
um and then i get back to the hotel it's
like 10 at night i'm like out like turn
on the tv just to see what's on
and then i turn it to c-span and it's my
event from earlier that day
well because there's a c-span camera and
it just like tracked the event
and then even in the receiving line
afterwards when i was talking to people
and i did not know this when they would
just come up to me and shake my hand and
ask me a question then i would answer
them
uh the c-span camera person just
recorded that entire thing where there's
like this entire receiving line there's
no commentary
all it is is just an hour and a half
of receiving line and andrew yang town
hall
um and in dubuque or wherever it was so
uh so that is what public programming or
programming in the public interest
could look like very very low ratings
you know you can imagine this thing that
has
a watermark being like this is
definitely happening like you know i've
got like the
the c-span camera watermark on it um
but i i believe that that this is
something that we have to aggressively
fight for
that there needs to be some kind of
investment in
authenticity and what really happened
and
uh presenting like a version of reality
that voters can
evaluate in a way that c-span example is
like so pure
is that it's so dull but there was no
commentary at all
it was just andrew yang talking to
people and then the receiving line
and and even now nina like i'm a media
commentator as i think you are too
[Laughter]
so they they have this thing where this
this event that we all saw just happened
and they're like what do you think just
happened and then
uh and and often what the commentators
say ends up
being uh very influential
in terms of the public conversation or
public evaluation
yeah and which is why i mean
everybody who has influence in this new
information ecosystem has has a
responsibility you know if it weren't
for this new information ecosystem
then you know someone like president
trump who uses twitter as his global
megaphone
would not have the audience that he does
have so
it is incredibly i would agree with you
but the point i would make then
again as as something that we all need
to be aware of is that
single influencers are often more
trusted in this day and age than any
kind of
traditional or established media now
that can be
also because they're a purveyor of
disinformation and i think that is like
the interesting thing about the coming
age of synthetic media as well because
it will take
the democratization of disinformation
one step
further when any youtuber can basically
create a video a piece of manipulated
video which
right now is only in the domain of a
hollywood
studio right somebody with loads of
special effects
artists and a multi-million dollar
budget i mean you can look at some of
the deep fake stuff on youtube but
there's um
one guy who's taken the irishman you
know scorsese's latest film which he
spent
millions on with a three-ray camera
and he just took free ai software to
kind of
do the de-aging and arguably what he did
one youtuber with some ai is much better
than what scorsese did with his special
teams of special effects artists and
special camera
so we're entering an age where
anybody can be an influencer which can
be used for
good but it can also be used for bad and
with synthetic media it means that
anybody can actually alter
your perception of the world so you can
get very philosophical about it
but it is i think again my book is just
to lay it out to put it in a conceptual
framework to say
this is what's happening because i think
the first step is understanding
and then only can we start really
talking about technical
policy and society-wide solutions and
this is where i hope
someone like you will take this into
on your platform into the public sphere
because i think it is one of the
most critical issues of the next decade
well the next few years really
mission accomplished nina uh the
apocalypse
is here and we have to try and fight it
and make it so that we can survive this
time um i agree with you that i think
the public trusts
individuals more instinctively than
media organizations at this point and i
benefited from that public trust
where there are a number of podcasters
that had me on their shows
and then because they were supportive
then
their followers or the people that
viewed it also became supportive so i
benefited from that relationship
and i now i believe i'm sort of part of
that
where there are folks who will watch
this and because they
they think that i'm an honest actor
uh but i agree with you that there are
folks
who are not very honest actors who also
can develop massive followings
um and in some cases it might be
more um frankly easy for them to develop
massive followings because
you can do something that's inflammatory
that a lot of people are kind of waiting
for
because a lot of people want to say like
i knew it like i knew those people
were up to no good i knew that you know
there was uh this conspiracy
at work like you know that's a human
impulse and if you want to develop a big
following you can
feed that impulse become very
popular and and then what's your next
move you guys got to keep feeding it
like that there are folks that have that
relationship too
uh so what you you call the infocalipse
like i i've thought about as the
cacophony it just like
at at some point you have so many voices
uh shouting that it's im impossible to
discern what the heck is going on
uh and then one of the things that many
rational people do is check out
they're like everyone's too angry too
shrill
i don't know what the heck is real from
not real and
uh you know it's not realistic for me to
invest
you know like hours and hours of time
like trying to figure out
uh like fact checking everything i see
you know like p
like that people aren't really wired
that way
um so i am on on board your mission is
now my mission
and uh we have to try and give people a
sense of what's real so that we can make
uh real decisions about how to solve
some of the problems and this now is
but you know what what this is nina like
this is a problem that prevents us from
solving other problems
uh and so that and so that that's where
my attention is focused right now is um
is we have to fix the machinery of
democracy
and at this point it's not enough to try
and get the right people embedded into
the machine you have to try and fix the
machine itself
because right now this machine that this
machine is breaking down in a way that
even if i stuck like a good person
uh in congress it's not going to save us
absolutely focus on the architecture the
machine i think we're
absolutely on the same page here andrew
i'm going to become the mechanic
nina and i know you are too thank you so
much for edifying us
nina's book is deep fakes the coming
infocalipse
uh it's compelling it's scary and
hopefully we will do something about it
together
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you